en parle et julie garnier oratrice
nationale de la france insoumise est
avec nous sur ce plateau julie garnier
bonjour merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation directe sur rt france on
vient d'entendre la colère de l'une des
figures du mouvement un jérôme rodrigues
très en colère vous vous la comprenez
cette colère je la comprends et je la
ressens et je lui apporte tout mon
soutien et on voit qui a pas
d'essoufflement vise essaye de faire en
sorte que nous balayer de nous un
visibiliser mais il n'y a pas
d'essoufflement il ya une vraie
détermination et malgré toutes les
interdictions qui met on voit que les
gens sont dans la rue et après 60 4
semaines ils sont toujours là ils sont
toujours là et pour parce que toutes les
semaines on leur donne des motifs pour
manifester toutes les semaines les gens
ressentent le mépris qu'il ya on peut
reprendre que cette semaine là et je
pourrais parler de la réforme des
retraites bien sûr mais on pourrait
parler aussi de cette répression qui a
dans les lycées nous on a des étudiants
qui seront des lycéens qui se retrouve
en garde à vue pourquoi pour avoir
manifesté pour s'être mobilisés dans
leur lycée pour avoir mis un début de
feu dans une poubelle qui n'avait rien
de dangereux
des enfants aux gars des vues voilà ce
qu'on a voilà ce que les gens voient et
ses répressions policières dont il parle
justement et à juste titre aujourd'hui
quand on parle de répression policière
on voit qu'il n'ya qu'un seul journal un
seul journal un seul papier qui reprend
l'appel des familles c'est l'humanité et
je tiens à le remercier pour ça mais
tous les autres
sur quoi ils ont fait leur une sur
bernard tapie sur la campagne de edouard
philippe au havre voilà ce qu'ils font
ils font du déni perpétuel et je le dis
il y aura des actes toutes les semaines
tant qu'il y aura du déni démocratique
c'est une évidence il n'y a que le
gouvernement pour pas l'avoir cette
évidence que c'est vrai qu'
effectivement pour revenir à cette
interdiction préfectorale les gilets
jaunes 10 bah ouais les syndicats eux
peuvent marcher là où ils veulent
pour manifester ce n'est pas notre cas
c'est vraiment selon vous une
discrimination plus qu'une question de
sécurité
je pense que le gouvernement a peur de
ce que représentent les gilet jaune
parce que c'est quelque chose qu'il ne
prévoit pas le mouvement syndicaliste
est un mouvement fondamentale est utile
mais c'est inscrit dans l'histoire de
francs
ce qui est complètement inédit dans
l'histoire de france ce mouvement d
gilet jaune et ce mouvement d gilet
jaune je pense qu emmanuel macron en a
peur la preuve regardez comment il a fui
à chaque fois quand il y avait des
manifestions qui n'était pas prévu que
ce soit quand il était au restaurant du
collectionneur au camp s'était au
théâtre il a peur de son peuple et quand
on est un président qui a peur de son
peuple qui ne peut pas sortir c'est que
le problème ce n'est pas le peuple c'est
le président et ça il ne veut pas le
voir
qu'est ce que vous attendez justement du
gouvernement face à cette colère qui
revient toutes les semaines depuis
soixante quatre semaines dans les rues
qu'est ce quelle attitude vous
attendez-vous aujourd'hui du
gouvernement j'attends qu'ils arrêtent
d'être méprisant et qu'il arrête d'être
dans le déni et qu'il considère les
urgences qui sont urgentes
on a des rapports qui nous disent qu'ils
se multiplient que l'urgence aujourd'hui
aller sociale quand on a un record
d'enfants dans la rue quand on a un
record de mutilés dans les
manifestations
quand on a un record d'hôpitaux en grève
depuis des mois quand on a la liberté de
la presse qui est bafouée quand on est
des conflits d'intérêts au plus haut
sommet de l'état
tout ça ça se cumulent qu'on met ça sur
la table parce que c'est ça l'urgence ce
n'est pas la réforme des retraites
qu'ils essayent de nous faire passer en
force
contre l'avis de toute la population
c'est l'urgence on sait où elle est et
on sait qu'il ne veut pas la traiter
parce qu'ils s'en fichent complètement
parce que lui tout son intérêt c'est de
répondre à ceux qui l'ont mis au pouvoir
c'est cette oligarchie ce 1% qui passe
en force contre les 99%
elle est là la réalité est ce que ça les
gens se rendent de plus en plus compte
cette grogne là elle ne s'arrêtera pas
tant que cette vérité là ne sera pas
perçue par emmanuel macron et quand le
chef de l'état justement dit qu'il n'y a
pas de violences policières mais une
société violente comment est ce que vous
comprenez ces propos qu'il ose dire ça
après la mort de cédric chouïa après les
vidéos qu'on a vu après laver borg et de
manu je ne comprends pas qu'on puisse
dire ça on a des vidéos qui montrent ces
gens là qui montre comment leur vie ont
basculé je suis désolé pour l'émotion
mais on peut tous être dans la rue on
peut tous se retrouver à manifester
parce que c'est
votre droit le plus fondamental et pour
avoir fait ça on peut se retrouver
métier qu'ils osent nier ça et qu'il ose
s'afficher avec une photo en souriant et
en faisant un affront finalement à
toutes ces personnes là je me dis que ce
président n'a n'a aucune légitimité
il ne se rend pas compte à quel point de
la blessure du mépris de l'infamie
finalement de son acte ne se rendrait
pas compte de ça aujourd'hui
ces répressions policières sont un fléau
pour notre démocratie et on peut je suis
désolé mais pensons pensons juste assez
26 éborgné et ils ont donc on peut tous
être manu talayssat jérôme alexandre
on peut tous être ces personnes là parce
qu'ils n'ont rien fait ils ont juste
fait ils ont juste appliqué en fait le
droit de manifester c'est tout ce qu'ils
ont fait et le droit d'être des
opposants politiques
c'est tout aujourd'hui du coup on
ressent bien votre votre émotion face à
cette fracture à 7
à ces difficultés dans notre société
vous attend vous attendez quoi comme
geste très concret finalement qu'il
arrête qu'il sait ce qu'ils retirent
qu'il retire ses réformes du dialogue
aussi une main tendue
la seule main tendue qui serait honnête
ça ferait faisons parler la démocratie
puisque vous voulez essayer la
démocratie puisque vous vous dites
démocrate et maintenant démocratie lit à
demos et ça veut dire peuple ça veut
dire laissons le peuple décider
c'est un référendum laisser les gens
décider laissez les gens jugés de vos
actes les cellules puisque c'est ça la
démocratie
eh ben mettez le en oeuvre arrêtez de
vouloir passer en force comme ça arrêtez
de vouloir dire mais on va vous pondre
mille pages et on va faire que et vous
avez que quatre jours pour justifier
là-dessus arrêté qu'est ce qu'il vous
faut tout s'est jeté de robe d'avocat
tout s'est jeté de stylos de livres
qu'est ce qu'il vous faut d'autres
qu'est ce qu'il lui faut il faut combien
de morts il faut combien d'enfants à la
rue qu'est ce qu'il lui faut pour qu'il
arrête et qu'ils comprennent maintenant
s'il veut vraiment faire un geste
le seul geste tu peux faire
ces arrêtés et de donner la parole au
peuple
parce que la démocratie fondamentalement
sont eux c'est le peuple c'est lui qui
doit décider si non ce n'est pas de la
démocratie
merci beaucoup julie garnier d'avoir
accepté notre invitation en direct sur
rt frange rappelle que vous êtes
oratrice nationale de la france un son
mythe
merci